bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette édition
du 16 octobre du journal de la rédaction
de votre télévision locale et dans
l'actualité aujourd'hui la CGT qui a
fait à mobilisation pour dénoncer le
projet de budget de la Sécurité sociale
dont l'examen débute à l'Assemblée
nationale 142 rassemblements en France
et une manifestation à Paris mais le
syndicat a eu du mal à fédérer la gare
Versailles chantier qui va prendre de
l'ampleur dans les deux ans le projet de
pôle multimodal vient d'être dévoilé 63
millions d'euros pour des
investissements devenus indispensables
Versailles chantier la deuxième guerre
d'Île de France avec 64000 voyageurs
chaque jour et puis le pôle de recherche
en microbiologie de l'alimentation au
service de la santé de l'INRA s'installe
dans de nouveaux locaux à Jouy-en-Josas
l'occasion de s'intéresser au travail
mené dans ces murs invités
le club phase de Saint-Quentin en
Yvelines qui fête ses 15 ans la
Fondation pour agir contre l'exclusion
qui intervient auprès des entreprises
locales pour mettre en place des actions
concrètes va célébrer son anniversaire
ce soir au Théâtre national à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux plus de 1000
personnes ont été accompagnées vers
l'emploi depuis la création ainsi que
3000 scolaires sensibilisés à la culture
d'entreprise
l'information a été donnée par Europe1
ce matin la ministre de l'Éducation
nationale un Najat Vallaud-Belkacem veut
revoir les aides accordées aux écoles
données plus aux académies ou les
résultats scolaires ne sont pas bons et
donc moins aux autres tout cela a budget
constant nous sommes en ligne avec
Bertrand mesure bonsoir
représentant du syndicat enseignant
SNUipp dans les Yvelines c'est une telle
mesure était appliquée cela signifierait
plus de moyens pour l'académie de
Versailles
l'Académie de la salle est une Académie
qui est déficitaire
depuis très longtemps l'ensemble des
comparaisons qui sont faites chaque
année par le ministère le démontre et il
est certain que ça nous apporterait
peut-être plus de moyens mais si c'est
pour en prendre ailleurs vous
comprendrez que donc pas vraiment
satisfaire de ce genre de perspective le
système actuel c'est une répartition des
moyens humains et financiers selon
vraiment un critère comptable le nombre
d'élèves ses proportionnels c'est
égalitaire mais ça ne fonctionne pas ça
veut dire que tout de même qu'il faut
revoir ce système
ez c'est fait égalitaire c'est à dire
que c'est effectivement des critères
comptables mais sur la base
d'indicateurs extrêmement
grossier comme par exemple le P sur
d'enseignants pour son élève et c'est
sûr que ça ne traduit pas ou ça ne
permet pas de prendre en compte toute la
spécificité de chacun des territoires en
particulier sur l'académie de Versailles
entre un département comme le 95 le 78
il y a des disparités extrêmement fortes
par exemple les 92 lui est complètement
urbanisé le 78 a des zones de grandes
pauvreté grande richesse des zones
rurales et tout ça ne fait pas un
ensemble homogène et uniforme alors que
si la possibilité à l'intérieur des
académies ce serait en tout cas le
projet de répartir différemment les
moyens de département à un autre d'une
école à une autre est-ce que ce serait
une bonne solution ou ce serait plutôt
nivelé par le vers le bas justement et
enlever et risquer que dans les endroits
où ça fonctionne ce soit plus compliqué
bah écoutez nous on serait déjà preneur
d'une définition d'indicateur qui serait
beaucoup plus précis et qui prendrait en
compte l'ensemble des paramètres de le
point de vue
des progrès en matière de transparence à
faire et c'est progrès permettrait
d'avoir une discussion certainement un
petit peu plus fine sur la façon dont
les moyens sont attribués et puis il y
aurait toujours ce problème c'est la
crise de la vocation parce que même si
les moyens sont attribués différemment
il manque toujours aujourd'hui des
enseignants alors ça c'est un autre
problème effectivement depuis cette
année notre Académie n'est pas à trouver
le nombre d'enseignants correspondants
au nombre de places offerts au concours
mais que ce soit en matière
d'encadrement comme d’être activité du
métier les études de l'OCDE ont démontré
que l'école primaire c'est la maternelle
et aimantaire et il part en pauvres de
l'éducation en France et en Europe merci
Bertrand mesure du SNUipp pour cette
première réaction à cette piste d'étude
visiblement du gouvernement de
redéployer de manière plus inégalitaire
donc les moyens dans les différentes
académies françaises plusieurs milliers
de manifestants ont défilent à Paris
aujourd'hui à l'appel de la CGT
plusieurs bus sont partis des Yvelines
vous allez le voir comme à trappe il
s'oppose au budget de la sécurité
sociale dont l'examen débute à
l'Assemblée nationale selon le syndicat
la sécurité sociale et c'est
fondamentaux sont aujourd'hui remis en
cause
ce qui pose problème c'est les nouvelles
méthodes sur la politique familiale qui
est attaquée et puis on peut on peut
financer autrement la sécurité sociale
on l'a fait alors que le pays était bien
plus malheureux que ça au moment de la
sortie de la guerre et on peut le faire
maintenant il y a pas de problème et
effectivement la mobilisation compte
parce qu'on s'aperçoit que le
gouvernement finalement recule quand il
y a une mobilisation importante alors on
veut que la mobilisation soit le plus
important possible
ça et la gare chantier va donc devenir
un pôle multimodal d'ici deux ans les
travaux sont actuellement en cours pour
réaménager et tendre cette gare ou
transit 64000 voyageurs chaque jour le
projet a été présenté hier mercredi
reportage Violaine Torres William elle
la gare de Versailles chantier en pleine
mutation le futur projet a été présenté
mercredi l'objectif rendre la gare plus
fluide plus accessible et surtout
multimodal
on vous répond c'est quelqu'un qui bouge
et il bouge avec tous les modes de
transport possible ici il y a 40 % des
usagers de la gare de Versailles les
64000 quotidiens 40% qui prennent un bus
pour repartir dans une autre direction
ok c'était très important de faire un
système multimodal parmi les grands axes
de ce pôle la rénovation du bâtiment des
voyageurs existants la création d'une
extension de 3000 mètres carrés
l'amélioration du parvis de la gare
ferroviaire mais aussi la création d'une
nouvelle gare routière et la refonte des
desserts existantes la SNCF s'investit
dans ce projet d'abord c'est pour nous
un très gros projet c'est plus de 60
millions d'euros qui sont investis pour
une gare qui est la deuxième gare en
Île-de-France évidemment en dehors des
grandes gares parisiennes il y a Juvisy
et Versailles chantier c'est la deuxième
gare c'est plus de 60000 clients tous
les jours ce projet va donc permettre de
requalifier le quartier et prévoit
également 40 000 m² de logement ou de
bureau l'enjeu il est économique et donc
ici était prévu un mini paraly 2 de
20000 mètres carrés j'ai dit non parce
que il faut protéger notre commerce de
centre-ville et il faut également qu'ici
on met plutôt des bureaux parce que les
bureaux d'abord ça rapporte de fiscalité
à l'intercommunalité et puis c'est ça
dont on a besoin le coût estimé à 63,6
millions d'euros et réparti entre l'État
la Région le Conseil général des
Yvelines la ville de Versailles le STIF
la SNCF et le Réseau Ferré de France
l'ouverture de ce futur pôle est prévu
dans deux ans
les cheminots ont profité de la venue du
président du Syndicat des transports
d'Île-de-France Jean-Paul Huchon donc
pour l'interpeller notamment sur les
baisses de moyens comme la fermeture des
guichets de proximité là aussi été
question de lutter contre les
incivilités envers les agents elle a la
direction se veut rassurante
il y a actuellement trois caisses la
direction refuse de créer un une caisse
en plus on a filmé à plusieurs reprises
il y a des queues de plus de 20-25
mètres de gens qui ne peuvent pas
acheter leur billet évidemment il y a
des détails de qu'il faudra régler par
exemple si vraiment pour la sécurité
c'est pas bien de pas avoir de glace
devant les employés parce qu'on va
mettre des glaces mais ça je m'en occupe
avec la SNCF bien sûr nous essayons de
de les aider à assumer cette
responsabilité face au public tous les
jours vous savez il y a
aujourd'hui plus de 10 millions de
personnes qui tous les jours voyage avec
nos trains nos métros nos bus et c'est
10 millions de personnes mais ils
portent aussi une part de la tension de
la société actuelle et qui se reflète
dans le contact avec nos agents c'est
très difficile ce qu'il faut tous les
jours et on le comprend et on fait tout
pour les aider
nous allons parler de science à présent
au cours des prochaines minutes l'unité
de recherche au microbiologie de
l'alimentation au service de la Santé
vient de déménager pour s'installer dans
un nouveau bâtiment de l'INRA à jouer en
jeuas le directeur de l'unité est déjà
en plateau ce soir nous revenons pour
l'instant sur l'inauguration du nouveau
site c'était hier mercredi soir avec ce
reportage de Catherine zulato Anthony
Rech et des images de Patrick Jacques de
Dixmude
dans ce bâtiment on étudie tout
particulièrement les micro-organismes
depuis leur rôle dans la fabrication des
aliments fermentés comme les yaourts ou
la charcuterie jusqu'à leur fonction
dans la digestion et leurs effets sur la
santé de l'homme on travaille sur des
microbes donc sur des bactéries alors à
la fois sur des bactéries qui sont je
vais vous dire gentilles donc vous
pouvez manipuler qui ne vous poseront
pas de problème et puis on travaille
aussi sur des bactéries qu'on appelle
pantogène ou pathogène opportuniste
essayez de comprendre les mécanismes qui
fait que de gentilles elle va devenir
méchante parce que c'est pas toujours
bien compris définir des pronostics
sanitaires guérir des pathologies comme
le diabète ou les maladies
cardiovasculaires en utilisant pourquoi
pas demain les micros organismes que
l'on étudie aujourd'hui le travail de
chercheur regroupe et dorénavant sur un
même site quand on est en laboratoire
taille modeste on n'a pas forcément les
moyens de s'équiper au niveau auquel les
des nouveaux défis scientifiques que
nous attendent plus de moyens plus
d'échanges aussi entre chercheurs une
nécessité pour répondre aux défis de
demain le nouveau bâtiment d'un coup de
19,3 millions d'euros a été subventionné
à hauteur de 9,2 millions d'euros par le
concert régional de France
l'Île-de-France qui accueille 40 % des
chercheurs français et un enjeu de
taille dans le cadre de l'on l’opération
d'intérêt national de Paris-Saclay
Yvelines
ça veut dire que on tient plus que la
Silicon Valley c'est plus que la série
Goldman c'est plus important quand vous
demandez un Américain pourquoi ils
viendrait s'implanter en Île-de-France
la réponse est presque tu joues à cause
de la qualité de la main d'oeuvre et la
qualité de la recherche et surtout la
jonction entre la recherche et
l'industrie alors c'est ici vraiment ce
qui se fait de plus remarquable
l'Institut mikaliste dédié à la
microbiologie de l'alimentation au
service de la santé regroupera sans
grande chercheurs
ingénieur enseignant et jusqu'à 130
doctorat
je reçois donc ce soir Stéphane emerich
bonsoir on vous avait eu dans ce
reportage vous êtes le directeur de
cette unité que l'on vient de découvrir
l'unité de microbiologie de
l'alimentation au service de la santé
humaine à l'unité mécaniste déménagement
nouveau locaux cela signifie plus de
moyens pour vous un confort plus grand
pour travailler mieux travailler tout à
fait ça nous ça signifie des locaux
techniques plus adaptés aux
expérimentations particulières et aux
conditions dans lesquelles on doit
réaliser ces expérimentations des
infrastructures qu'on partage qui sont
de plus en plus onéreuses et qu'on peut
pas acquérir à l'échelle de petits
laboratoires c'est pour c'est une des
raisons pour lesquelles nous ne
regroupons on parle souvent des manques
de moyens pour la science pour la
recherche tout se passe bien pour vous
finalement
dans tous ne va pas pour le mieux dans
le meilleur des mondes possibles mais
avec grâce aux efforts de l'ensemble des
personnels et des chambres l'ensemble
des responsables d'équipes on arrive
effectivement à poursuivre nos
l'essentiel de nos projets mais c'est
vrai les temps sont un petit peu pour la
recherche également on va s'intéresser
justement à l'objet de vos recherches la
biologie de l'alimentation concrètement
on étudie quoi alors on étudie en fait
les micro-organismes qui sont liés à
l'alimentation alors ces
micro-organismes ils sont liés soit à la
fabrication des aliments par exemple
vous ne pouvez pas fabriquer un yaourt
sans micro-organismes le transformer le
lait en yaourt grâce à des
micro-organismes vous faites de la
charcuterie vous conservez la
charcuterie grâce à des micro-organismes
donc on étudie
la façon dont ces micro-organismes
agissent pour transformer les matières
premières on étudie ensuite des
micro-organismes qui nous aident à
digérer ces aliments les micronistes que
nous hébergeons dans notre tube digestif
et en particulier dans notre gros
intestin on a
100000 milliards de bactéries dans cette
intestin ça représente à peu près 2 kg
de matière donc et c'est essentiel non
seulement pour digérer les aliments mais
on s'aperçoit depuis on s'est aperçu
depuis quelques années c'est une
véritable révolution dans le pour le
monde scientifique que
cet ensemble de micro-organismes qu'on
appelle microbiote intestinal
à un rôle essentiel pour le
développement notre développement et le
maintien de notre santé et de temps en
temps quand il a été agressé quand il a
été déséquilibré par tel ou telle
condition le microbiote peut être au
contraire associée à des pathologies
chroniques telles que des inflammations
chroniques de l'intestin tel que
l'obésité telle que des formes de
diabète ça veut dire qu'on étudiant le
mode de fonctionnement naturel on
pourrait réparer si ça ne fonctionnait
plus c'est aussi le but de vos
recherches on étudie alors pour
comprendre ce qui est essentiel
finalement on étudie souvent les
conditions
qui préside dans des chez des individus
justement malades et on les compare
c'est dans les comparant avec ce qui se
passe dans les individus qu'on découvre
ce qui est essentiel pour favoriser ou
contrat pour empêcher la maladie et oui
oui nous avons quelques exemples
on est en train de développer des
exemples
à travers lesquels on pourrait guérir
des pathologies en apportant des
micro-organismes
soit qui qu'on a repéré pour posséder
dans tel ou telle particularité telle ou
telle propriété soit en les transformant
en leur greffant une propriété
intéressante dans le cadre de la
protection ou de la guérison de telle ou
telle maladie tout cela prend beaucoup
de temps à quelle échéance on peut
imaginer une mise en application
concrète des recherches que vous menez
laboratoire qui existe depuis l'unité de
recherche depuis 2010 même si vous devez
déménager CES 2010 la crème
c'est un laboratoire qui en fait réunit
des laboratoires qui existaient
préalablement donc d'une certaine il y a
malgré tout une certaine continuité dans
les projets scientifiques ce nouveau
bâtiment nous donne de nouveaux moyens
nous donne un nouvel élan mais c'est il
y a une continuité dans les dans les
projets oui c'est souvent des projets à
long terme mais on a je vous le répète
donc déjà des applications qu'on cherche
à développer à transférer
en particulier donc auprès de start-up
qui quelquefois on a un exemple de
start-up cré à partir vous pouvez citer
ces exemples ou ça reste du domaine
confidentiel parce que c'est encore bien
sûr en terreau est une start-up dont
vous pouvez trouver le site sur Internet
et qui est créé à partir et sous
l'impulsion de chercheurs du laboratoire
mécanisme et qui vise
dans un premier temps au moins à
proposer des solutions de diagnostic
voir de pronostics de d'état
pathologique donc présents ou futur
comment si tu la France par rapport à
tous ces domaines de recherche justement
alors cet homme une source de fierté
parce que dans ce domaine de l'étude du
microbiote intestinal on peut réellement
dire que le laboratoire mécanisme est le
leader européen et parmi les
laboratoires qui comptent sur la scène
internationale sur certains aspects de
cette étude sur un type d'approche
particulier qui consiste à séquencer
l'ensemble des génomes des bactéries
qu'on nous avons dans notre intestin on
peut même dire qu'on a été les pionniers
on a lancé le mouvement général avec une
conférence qu'on a organisée en 2005
et c'est un champ qui explose qui
aujourd'hui il y a de très grands
laboratoires partout dans le monde qui
poursuivent
ces mêmes objectifs à travers l'étude du
microbiote intestinal il y a une
concurrence entre pays certains s'en
vont par exemple chercheurs de l'inrad
vos unités de recherche sont sollicités
pour partir à l'étranger ils sont
quelquefois sollicités
en général heureusement il
répondent pas parce qu'on offre et en
particulier grâce à nouveau bâtiments de
bonnes conditions mais j'ai aussi
quelques exemples inverse justement
mais aussi d'arriver bien entendu grâce
à grâce le nouveau bâtiment c'est aussi
une source d'attractivité de visibilité
de manière générale de l'unité et de nos
travaux et donc d'attractivité de jeunes
ou de seniors vers nos laboratoires et
nos thèmes de recherche donc c'est une
vraie vitrine la région les pouvoirs
publics vous soutiennent ils ont financé
une grande partie de ce bâtiment c'est
l'unique source c'est l'unique non
pouvoir publique uniquement qui
s'intéresse à vous il y a des
entreprises privées aussi qui vous
demandent des recherches spécifiques
de la région et de l'État pour le
bâtiment elle a été essentielle mais
elle elle est
se limite on strict strictement au
bâtiment alors on a d'autres on
recherche de l'aide publique à travers
des appels d'offres qui sont lancés par
l'Agence nationale de la recherche créer
il y a maintenant une petite dizaine
d'années donc qui nous apporte on va
dire
de près ou de loin une petite moitié de
nos ressources de fonctionnement pour
faire tourner le laboratoire tous les
jours
un petit quart vient de projet européen
on les appelle d'offres européens donc
c'est l'argent essentiellement public
mais qui vient de l'Europe et puis le
dernier quart nous vient à travers des
contrats avec des entreprises privées
de grandes entreprises des entreprises
de taille plus modestes de
l'agroalimentaire de la voie alimentaire
et du et aussi du
secteurs
particulier qui est porté peut-être plus
encore en France sur ce qu'on mange sur
l'alimentation ça veut dire que vous
travaillez aussi à la vérification des
normes à l'élaboration de nouvelles
normes
le sujet mais c'est l'objectif aussi
dans le journal souvent on parle et on
en a parlé aussi ici avec des
associations de consommateurs de dates
limites de consommation ou de péremption
qui sont bien bien trop tôt et on
pourrait entendre et conserver un peu
plus c'est vrai c'est vérifié on
pourrait conserver plus et on met des
dates un petit peu trop tôt je peux pas
en rassurer on se prémunit au maximum de
tourisme il faut mieux trop prévenir
c'est l'intérêt public on peut on ne
peut enfin je peux on peut comprendre
que les pouvoirs publics prennent le
maximum de précaution même si bien
entendu pour certains industriels pour
certains distributeurs ou consommateurs
ça peut sembler un petit peu abusif vous
avez tous fait d'expérience de manger un
yaourt qui a été correctement conservé
au réfrigérateur un petit peu après ça
date limite sans aucun problème bien
entendu mais ça peut pas être encouragé
par les pouvoirs publics je peux pas
bien sûr
merci Stéphane brise d'être venu sur le
plateau l'unité de microbiologie de
l'alimentation donc il s'est installé à
jouer aux choses là c'était très
intéressant merci à vous on reste dans
la recherche et toujours avec l'INRA
d'ailleurs qui depuis 16 ans test avec
veoliade et compost d'origine urbaine
dans un champ de maïs et de blé les
compare avec des engrais plus classiques
les premiers résultats ont été dévoilés
reportages les pieds dans la boue pour
Claire Cambier et Patrick Jacques de
dixmes
là j'en ai un petit ramasser des vers de
terre fait aussi partie du métier des
scientifiques de l'INRA dans ce champ on
cherche à mesurer l'activité biologique
des sols donc en fait on met du produit
irritant sur le sol pour les faire
remonter ça fonctionne très bien en ce
moment là et ensuite on creuse un
monolith de sol sur 20 cm de profondeur
qu'on trie manuellement pour récupérer
ce qui ne serait pas remonter à la
surface l'objectif est de comparer des
composts d'origine urbaine ordures
ménagères résiduelle biodéchet et bout
avec des engrais plus classiques comme
le fumier ou la fertilisation minérale
depuis 1998 des tests sont effectués
dans ce champ de fucherolles 6 hectares
divisés en 40 parcelles où on a très peu
d'élevage et donc très peu d'entrée de
matière organique par le biais de des
fluend d’élevage et donc il faut trouver
d'autres sources d'où l'intérêt de la
mise en place de ce site en
Île-de-France les terres sont très
pauvres en matière organique notamment
en carbone le but est donc de trouver le
compost qui puisse faire office de
sources alternatives pendant 16 ans
d'expérimentation l'INRA en
collaboration avec Veolia à multiplier
les tests prélèvement de sol et de
végétaux mesurent de la qualité de l'eau
ou encore de l'humidité et de la
température via des capteurs qui sont
implantés jusqu'à 1m62 de profondeur
et donc toutes ces données sont
recueillies il y a des centrales de
mesure donc qui se présente comme comme
ceci cette machine au sol permet
également de capturer les gaz à effet de
serre pour en mesurer les flux le bilan
est plutôt positif même si le cuivre et
le zinc sont un peu plus présent on
compte une hausse de 30 à 50% de la
matière organique des sols par rapport à
une fertilisation minérale le plus
efficace pour la matière organique ce
sont les composts de biodéchets donc ils
sont issus d'un mélange de déchets verts
et de la fraction fermentée cible des
ordures ménagères et le second type de
compost qui est très intéressant c'est
le compost debout d'épuration où c'est
des boom mélangés à des déchets verts
qui sont composés et qui sont très
efficaces pour augmenter la matière
organique mais qui en plus ont un effet
fertilisant très intéressant en termes
de d'azote et de phosphore bilan des
propriétés physiques et biologiques
améliorées
16 octobre 2013 les sages-femmes avaient
entamé un mouvement de grève nationale
pour obtenir plus de reconnaissance les
choses ont-elles évoluer les
revendications ont-elles finalement été
entendues le point un an après avec
Yolaine Torres
un an après les sages-femmes sont
toujours mobilisés le 16 octobre 2013
elles avaient entamé un mouvement de
grève nationale pour plus de
reconnaissance de leur statut et de leur
compétences un an après les demandes de
sage-femme malgré les annonces de la
ministre de la santé non pas été
entendus les sages-femmes souhaitent
notamment un statut médical spécifique
au sein des hôpitaux et des cliniques
privées une apparition sur le prochain
plan de Perrine natalité du ministère de
la Santé et réclame que leur formation
soit reconnue bac + 5 et non plus 3
comme aujourd'hui des revendications
qu'elles ont du mal à faire entendre il
y a pas beaucoup de professions qui sont
en grève pendant un an et dont on parle
si peu finalement un an de grève si on
regarde dans les mouvements sociaux ça
n'arrive jamais sauf que nous les
sages-femmes on a cette particularité
comme beaucoup c'est que quand on est en
grève on est réquisitionné on est
assigné c'est à dire qu'on est obligé de
travailler donc au final ça fait pas
tellement de vagues parce que bah oui on
est en grève mais on continue on
continue de prendre en charge nos
patientes leur un etc les 24 000
sages-femmes n'ont toutefois pas dit
leur dernier mot elles entamment une
deuxième année de grève et reste bel et
bien mobilisée
la semaine bleue c'est en ce moment et
jusqu'au 19 octobre une semaine dédiée
au retraitée aux personnes âgées avec
pour thème cette année créatifs et
citoyens à tout âge plusieurs
rendez-vous en France donc et dans les
Yvelines demain 17 octobre à 10h par
exemple la coordination gérontologique
locale propose un forum bien vivre à
domicile avec des ateliers marche
mémoires équilibre informatique ce sera
à Meulan à Guyancourt plus proche de
nous la semaine bleue se prolongera même
jusqu'en novembre le 6 une conférence
sur le sommeil avec un médecin attaché
au laboratoire du sommeil à l'hôpital
Béclère et puis pour terminer on notera
également dans un autre registre ce
vendredi à Versailles elle a
représentation au théâtre montentier
d'une pièce autour de la maladie
d'Alzheimer scénarisé et interprété par
Colette Roumanoff mère de l'humoriste
anormanov le reportage complet vous
voyez les images de cette pièce
reportage complet et sur ce spectacle
est à retrouver dès à présent sur notre
site internet
fin de ce journal on se retrouve demain
aux mêmes horaires pour l'édition du
week-end comme chaque vendredi
l'essentiel de la semaine mais aussi le
point sur les informations du jour votre
soirée sur tvfils c'est avec Floran
parfait pour un nouveau numéro de philo
n'oubliez pas les replay de tous nos
programmes sur notre site et puis les
réseaux sociaux pour les partager très
bonne soirée à demain